wie kommt einer neuen sendung von viel
lokales diesmal ist mein
gesprächspartner hendrik und der
hendrick promoviert zurzeit zum thema
realismus realismus was hat es damit
eigentlich auf sich
das ist realismus ja hallo erst mal und
zum thema realismus das sicherlich einer
der dauerbrenner der philosophie sowohl
historisch als auch systematisch nach
wie vor oder jetzt auch mit einem eine
art renaissance tatsächlich wieder mehr
und stärker erforscht und erstmals
vielleicht einzugrenzen realismus im
philosophischen sinne im gegensatz zu
realismus im alltag sprachlichen sinne
ich habe da eine anekdote und zwar hat
mich mal jemand gefragt mit wem ich mich
so beschäftige in der philosophie und
dann sagte ich beschäftige mich gerade
hauptsächlich mit dem realismus problem
und dann sagte sie zu mir ja das haben
viele ja und also philosophische
realismus heißt natürlich nicht dass
sich sozusagen weniger adäquat der
wirklichkeit gegenüber eingestellt bin
also ist etwas im psychologischen sinne
zum beispiel realistisch also ist es
realistisch dass sich in zwei jahren mit
philosophie millionär sein werde
es ist sehr unrealistisch aber das
interessiert nicht im philosophischen
realismus problem dazu haben wir auch
ein anderes video über berufsaussichten
der philosophie frage millionen oder
nicht aber ist ein anderes thema genau
zwar das philosophische realismus
problem kommt in ganz verschiedenen
fassungen und ist in ganz verschiedenen
fassungen aufgefasst worden kommt aber
ursprünglich vom lateinischen rees also
die sachen und die frage ist eben wie
ist es um die sachen bestellt gibt es am
gegenstände unabhängig von mentalen
kategorien die wir auf diese gegenstände
leben oder das ist die welt als ensemble
von gegenständen erkennbar und existiert
sie unabhängig von unseren metallenen
kategorien mode
unsere beobachtungen dieser wirklichkeit
also gibt es gebe es diese wirklichkeit
auch dann wenn wir sie nicht beobachten
würden oder wenn wir sie nicht in einer
bestimmten weise mental oder kann
real irgendwie über formen würden wobei
man da sicherlich auch noch mal jetzt in
der neueren fassungen des realismus
problems ein paar differenzierungen
anbringen muss so dass man diese these
von geist abhängigkeit versus geist
unabhängigkeit sicherlich in der
kontemporären realismus debatte nicht so
anders aus das ist jetzt eine sehr gute
einführung in diesem begriff könntest du
so ein paar neuere debatten mal kurz
anreißen die idee ist dass realismus
problem betreffen erneuere debatten also
erstmal muss man dazu sicherlich sagen
dass in der terminologie allein wir in
der analytischen philosophie heute von
dem gegensatz von realismus und anti
realismus sprechen also nicht realismus
und idealismus genau das ist ja im
grunde einer schöpfen der begriff ist
für alle möglichen varianten als ob wir
dann natürlich auch der klassischen
deutschen philosophie oder aus der
antiken philosophie vor allem die
begriffe idealismus und realismus
vertraut sind sind die gegenspieler des
realismus mit dem begriff anti realismus
sehr viel vielfältige einsätze zum
beispiel auch ein konstruktives muss
eine realismus letztlich und das ist
eine spannende frage vielleicht doch ein
nominales muss oder es domina liz muss
letztlich realismus das sind alles
sachen die diskutiert werden und
versucht worden sind auf dieses
gegensatzpaar von realismus und anti
realismus als sozusagen umfassendste
voraussetzungen dessen wie die frage des
realismus überhaupt sinn für gestellt
werden kann entwickelt kannst du uns zum
schluss noch ein konkretes
anwendungsfeld dieses dieser realismus
materialismus debatte nennen worin wird
dieses problem besonders deutlich
greifbar
ja da würde ich vielleicht erst mal auf
zwei debatten verweisen einmal diese
klassische systeme logische oder
metaphysische debatte ist es möglich
dass wir gegenstände erfahren können
oder sie erkennen können
unabhängig davon dass wir das erkennen
selbst in diese gegenstände hineinlegen
das wäre ja mal
kann zb diesen kategorien die wir haben
ist eine frage die subjektivität bei
kann der erkenntnistheorie machte ihn zu
einem anti realisten oder zu einem
realisten ist eine spannende frage
sicherlich bekannt genau dass wir sagen
frage wie man jetzt aus der heutigen
perspektive vielleicht gar nicht
glasklar beantworten keinen handel ist
ein realist er dann an die real ist das
aber der springende punkt dass ich gerne
mehr vorhaben würde ist dass wir heute
auch von sprachlichen über formen oder
semantischen bedingungen ausgehen die
also diesen gegenstands bezug versuchen
mehr sprachlich zu fassen bzw
theoretisch vielleicht auch zu fassen
also in der wissenschaftstheorie
diskutiert man das ja auch sehr häufig
in bezug auf die identitäten in
wissenschaftlichen theorien diese
vorkommen er hat solche nicht
beobachtbar sind also kleinste teilchen
in der quarks oder strings genauso ein
beispiel aus der physik und diese
teilchen werden ja nicht direkt
beobachtet sondern die beiden in der
theorie postuliert aber bei dem was man
dann heraus bekommt kann man wieder gute
physik betreiben und letztlich auch
unsere welt technologisch manipuliere
und dann ist die frage müssen wir
deswegen jetzt die existenz dieser
teilchen annehmen damit ist das aber
eine frage zwischen dem bezug von
theorien zur wirklichkeit man könnte
aber meiner meinung nach dem eine
ähnliche fassung geben wie dem
klassischen realismus problem nämlich
diese wenn man die realität wegnehmen
würde dann wäre die realität immer noch
so beschaffen auch ohne theorie das
heißt dann sind da auch diese teilchen
und quarks während an letzterem hand die
realistisch und am instrument alles muss
ist ja eigentlich nur um die theorie
geht können wir damit gute vorhersagen
machen aber die wirklichkeit außerhalb
der theorie dafür halt nur das
agnostisch oder es ist nicht das worauf
es ankommt es geht um die gute
vorhersagbarkeit wir müssen uns aber
nicht auf die existenz und quantität in
festlicher pflichten ja das ist mir sehr
klar geworden wie henrik vielen dank für
deine auskunft über dieses sehr
spannende thema wir sehen uns bei einer
neuen sendung von 4cast